i'm the mean shark i'm not the mean
shark i'm the only shark that tells the
truth
my wife's sitting there and with my
daughter and he stops and says to them
hey that guy from shark tank is sitting
is in the can that [ __ ] kevin o'leary
and linda says i know
[Music]
hey mr wonderful here in sunny florida
beautiful day really hot
humid and i just thought it would be a
great chance to talk about a few topics
that
i've been getting a lot of questions
about but before we start this episode
of ask mr wonderful
is sponsored by tiege hanley now i don't
endorse products i don't use and i don't
really get into men's skin
care that much except i really care
about taking care
of my face and my dome i call it the
dome of desire because
there's a lot of sun out here and i'm
outside all the time
why not that's why you're one of the
reasons you hang out in florida is to
enjoy the great sunshine the outdoors
beautiful ocean you can see here
but you can really damage your skin
including your neck like you really get
fried when you're biking
so teach hanley is a subscription
service if you don't know anything about
men's skin care this is for you
because everything comes in one box you
get
i go with the level one it's 25 bucks
but
everything you need now i use a lot of
makeup
during the day like this this kind of
anti-shine stuff
it gets in your pores particularly
around your nose so
there's a scrub used twice a week kind
of pushes that out of your pores
and then there's a moisturizer the key
to keeping yourself looking great is
moisturizing your skin
so the pm moisturizer i use every night
and then
like i haven't even done today's yet but
the am
which is terrific this is the day
moisturizer this is good because it's
fpf spf 20 so that's going to protect
against the sun
so i'm going to do it right now here's
the box you can see it
really cool i mean i i just it comes you
don't think about it
it's great and there's a special offer
by the way for all of my subscribers
just
look in the description click the link
and get the free toilet kit you can put
this stuff
in you know i've got a couple of them i
use them when i'm traveling all the time
and you don't have to think about it but
before i go out
i always put this on so check this out
this is fpf spf 20 the am
start with the dome if you have one dome
of desire protect it
always putting this on feels good too
i don't like a lot of perfume you don't
get that here it's just a basic
moisturizer check this out the neck
you know because your v collar is going
to fry you when you're on the bike or
something i cycle all over the place
here i know this is an extended
commercial but
i don't care i got to put this on my
face get it under your eyes
you don't burn your eyes your nose top
of my ears like that
the whole idea when you're in this
center of tropical climate stuff is
respect the sun because it can really
screw you up
and keep your skin moist that's it
pretty basic and of course exfoliate it
to get all the crap and the junk and the
whole city pollution thing out of the
way there you have it
thank you teach hanley all right now
let's talk about something else
so i'm tired of being called the mean
guy
because i'm not being mean
is different than telling the truth all
the time and i've said this
multiple times my mother taught me years
ago always tell the truth you never have
to remember what you said
and i would argue that if you're
truthful you'll be more successful
and here's why okay
the whole idea let me tell you a story
you know this whole shark tank thing and
no one thought the show would work and
all that here we are going to season 13
and i'm the mean shark i'm not the mean
shark
i'm the only shark that tells the truth
that's why i'm being called me and i'm
getting a little tired of it frankly and
i'm pushing back a little bit because
i think the truth has served everybody
well over the last decade
on shark tank but i remember early on
when we were taping
boston logan i go into the
at least i think it was boston logan so
long ago was an airport anyways i go
into the men's room my daughter and wife
are waiting for me outside
and this guy i'm doing my business
and the sky in my right keeps looking at
me
you know it's never happened before and
he probably looked at me three times and
he said
are you that guy on shark tank and i
said yeah like
like it never happened before i say gee
if somebody's finally watching the show
besides a cat and a dog
this is amazing that's what i'm saying
to myself and he says
you're an [ __ ] i went what
why would you say that he said those two
guys on last night
you took 51 percent of their business
and they're just starting out
i said yeah i gave the guys a quarter of
a million dollars they didn't know what
they were doing and i'm willing to work
with them to grow their business et
cetera he said that's just being too
greedy
you know there we are fighting it out in
the can i said look a lot of stuff gets
worked out in toilets but not this deal
i'm happy with what i did and he storms
out and
i didn't find this out till later but my
wife's sitting there
and with my daughter and he stops and
says to them hey
that guy from shark tank is sitting is
in the can that [ __ ] kevin o'leary
and linda says i know
i'm not sure if she was trying to make a
joke out of that but the point is it
goes to my whole theme about telling the
truth
i didn't lie to the guy i mean he called
me an [ __ ] for what because i'm
trying to do a deal a real
deal where i'm trying to help a company
out anyways the years roll on okay and
here's what i've learned
do you think it's better i'll ask you do
you think it's better
that somebody sitting in front of you
you know their idea is not going to work
it could be on shark tank it could be
anywhere
you know it's not going to work and and
and then you say that and they say well
look will you give me a quarter of a
million dollars will you fund my
business will you give me 50 000 you
give you a million whatever the number
is and you say
no no i'm not going to do that but i
think you're doing a great job you don't
need my money or
you just keep going maybe you can
mortgage your house or i think you're
terrific being an entrepreneur is
wonderful
without ever saying them your idea sucks
it's going to go to zero and you're
gonna wipe out your family
that's what i would say that's what i do
say
and and i get i get
you know people pissed off at me for
that meanwhile everybody else is saying
oh kumbaya
kumbaya you're so wonderful but i'm not
giving you any money
and you're not helping them out at all
because you're basically not telling
them the truth
an entrepreneur should be able to tell
the truth you should be able to speak to
them honestly they should be able to
take it in
and they should be able to fail even i
mean maybe they're coming to you at the
end of the deal after three years
nothing's working out and my rules are
very simple if you can't make money
after three years
it's a hobby it's not a business
i don't know why people give me crap for
this i mean it's so reasonable but the
point is
you tell them the truth they absorb it
they think about it at least you're
dealing in the
in the in the truth and you're not lying
to them but keep going and mortgage your
house and all that
but the reason i think it's more
efficient is you only have so much time
to be successful and you don't want to
waste it
there's nothing worse than wasting time
36 months that's enough time to figure
out if a business is going to work or
not right
point one point two you wanna be
successful
work with people that can achieve goals
also in other words
find executional skills men or women
that you can work with that when you set
a goal you say okay we're going to get
to a million in sales
in six months that they can actually do
that
because if you surround yourself with
people even if you don't like them
that can actually execute be given goals
and execute that's a
big deal my whole life i've learned that
lesson i've always tried to surround
myself with people
that have executional skills that are
better at me at some things
particularly like i don't like making
widgets i hate logistics and
manufacturing it sucks
i don't like it but i find people that
know how to do it
and are willing to set goals and achieve
them
and i compensate them very very well for
that because i want them to stay
i'm a marketer i'm a salesman i set
goals i achieve them i try and do it
consistently the greatest thing about
sales about identifying
talent and sales to achieve success is
consistency
don't set goals that they can't achieve
but set goals that they agree to
and let them achieve them consistently
consistency in sales lets you allocate
your capital
properly if you know you need so much
inventory because you know you can hit
your sales goal
every quarter you allocate that capital
you don't waste it you don't build more
than you need
cash is precious you can't burn it up
there's nothing worse than
saying oh yeah we can hit this crazy
high sales goal build the inventory for
it
and not sell it and the inventory goes
stale and you kill the money that kind
of thing that's what i'm talking about
do you have to love somebody to work
with them do you have to like them even
no you have to respect them you have to
respect them
i'll say it a third time you have to
respect them that's what matters respect
because they're able to achieve goals
that's what matters
all right something else i think you
should think about
the world is changing a lot this whole
idea of nine to five is being thrown out
the window why because about 15
of the population is never going back to
the office so think about changing the
way
you work in other words if somebody says
to you look i really want you to be
sitting at your desk nine to five you
say
why why is that important why don't you
just give me a goal for the week to
achieve
and i'll work whenever i want that's the
way i work now anyways i get up at two
in the morning and do stuff
there is no nine to five anymore there's
a goal
there's a task there's something you
have to get done
and you've got x amount of time to do it
that's the new
normal that's the way the world's going
to work so you want to kind of adjust
yourself
to think about all right i can do this i
can get this down
but i may change my mode of operation
maybe i'm gonna work at
two in the morning maybe i get up at
five maybe i have a snooze
all these things have changed i'm really
goal focused
i really am if i have to get something
done by five o'clock that day
i get it done by one o'clock i don't
wait to the deadline
maybe i get up and do it first thing i
block my days off into 30 minute chunks
and i get it done
try it it works doesn't matter what you
do doesn't matter what you do
if you basically say these are the five
things i'm going to nail today
and i'm not going to let anything get in
the way
watch how productive you'll become watch
how you'll achieve your goals watch how
people
want to work with you watch how they'll
want to be part of your world
people respect work but they
really respect execution excellence
and above all they love consistency and
above all that
they respect honesty even though it's
really hard to be honest all the time
suck it up and do it
it'll serve you well your whole life
remember what my mother said you'll
never have to remember what you said
why because you told the truth in the
beginning
what's more damaging than anything in
business or in a relationship
getting caught in a lie don't do it
if you like that video wait do you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe